et ben écoutez bonjour à tous ravi de
vous retrouver pour cette table ronde
que j'ai le plaisir d'animer avec nos
invités tous prestigieux que je vais
vous présenter au fur et à mesure de
leurs interventions parce que on a 1h15
prévue pour cette table ronde comme
comme toutes nos tables rondes et sur un
sujet
éminemment et je vois que vous êtes déjà
nombreux qui est
passionnant mais surtout actuellement
inquiétant
qui est un sujet qui interroge notre
partie est bien au-delà depuis très
longtemps puis des années puisque la
question de la question de
l'interrogation sur la démocratie fait
partie des sujets permanents et pour
notre famille politique est un sujet de
réflexion permanent mais là ça va
au-delà de la réflexion j'ai envie de
dire maintenant on doit on doit être
dans l'action on dans les remèdes on les
au modem déjà depuis longtemps comme je
vous dis et de façon très concrète
depuis trois ans puisque avec un certain
nombre de nos amis ici présents Elodie
Sarah Patrick nous avions eu l'occasion
de travailler avec Jean-Noël sur la
question de l'abstention en publiant un
livre blanc sur ce sujet de le présenter
dans le cadre des travaux parlementaires
à l'Assemblée nationale durant la
dernière mandature présenter des
solutions concrètes et autour de ce
livre blanc d'animer régulièrement cette
réflexion de la nourrir avec vous
militants acteurs de terrain que vous
êtes les mères et d'avoir encore pu
début juillet animer une une
visioconférence sur cette question qui a
réuni plus d'une centaine d'entre vous
donc je sais que ce sujet vous préoccupe
et c'est heureux que nous puissions en
débattre cet après-midi durant une bonne
heure
comme on est dans un temps quand même
contraint je vais donner les règles du
jeu à nos invités pour vous permettre
aussi d'intervenir et
d'interagir avec avec nous après c'est
que vous allez avoir un propoliminaire
cadré 4 minutes chacun et pour commencer
puisque et il faut les tenir et je sais
qu'ils sont capables de les tenir parce
qu'on a l'habitude et pour certains sont
des intervenants qui travaillent dans un
cas de contraint dans leur assemblée
donc vous savez le faire donc Sarah tu
vas avoir la primeur de commencer et tu
es notre invité je ne sais pas si on
doit te présenter mais je te présente
quand même d'opter notre secrétaire
d'État et on en est très fier sur les
questions jeunesse et c'est un plaisir
et un honneur que t'accueillir bravo
et parce que ça nous fait du bien de
t'avoir et parce qu'on sait que la
jeunesse sur ces questions c'est
fondamental et c'est celle qu'il faut et
c'est celle qu'il faut aussi
entraîner dans cette vie publique et
dans cette vie des démocratique tu es
député à l'origine pas très loin d'ici
de Loire-Atlantique tu as un super
parcours tu fais un travail formidable
il faut le dire tu l'as fait à
l'Assemblée nationale tu l'as fait dans
tes différentes responsabilités auprès
de Jean-Michel Blanquer et maintenant de
papendaye et Dieu sait si c'est un sujet
qui nous intéresse donc je te laisse la
parole tu connais les consignes et voilà
tu as un micro un côté de toi donc à toi
merci merci beaucoup Isabelle bonjour à
tous Alors on s'était dit 14h30 c'est
l'heure où finalement il y a où toute
l'attention ou le moment de la digestion
et en fait vous êtes hyper nombreux ça
veut dire à quel point pour notre parti
politique pour notre famille politique
la démocratie et au-delà d'être un sujet
c'est un c'est un de nos fondamentaux et
je suis très heureuse de retrouver en
tribune en réalité des amis avec qui on
a mené un certain nombre de combats dans
des instances dans des institutions
différentes mais comme le temps est
compté et que ce moment je pense est
autant grave qu'important je souhaite
que cette table ronde elle soit franche
et que finalement peut-être on ne tourne
pas autour du pot ça veut dire quoi de
manière très claire est-ce que notre
démocratie va bien la réponse est non et
je pense que ce constat on le partage
tous mais ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que nous sommes en train de vivre dans
un moment où notre jeunesse en
particulier mais pas que vie et bien des
changements le monde a changé quand je
dis le monde a changé il va plus vite
les chaînes continuent Internet les fake
news le complotisme
mais il y a aussi en réalité la montée
d'une certaine manière des changements
des pratiques où sont les familles où
est l'éducation civique et morale et
tout ça nous amène un monde où dans nos
démocraties occidentales la démocratie
est bousculée il suffit de regarder je
sais que un certain nombre d'entre nous
reviendront peut-être sur les sur le
point européen mais le visage et les
pratiques ayant changé alors ça crée
beaucoup de bouleversements est-ce que
notre démocratie la manière de pratiquer
notre démocratie a changé la réponse est
non on n'a pas fait évoluer notre
manière de pratiquer la démocratie et
donc comme on n'a pas fait évoluer notre
que le monde a changé on se retrouve
face à une démocratie qui ne va pas bien
un vote qui n'attire pas alors même que
chaque position chaque décision est plus
que jamais politique donc nous sommes
dans un monde qui est plus que jamais
politique aujourd'hui la question de
l'eau de l'égalité de la lutte contre
les discriminations de la cohésion
sociale du patriotisme ce sont des
projet politique ce ne sont pas que des
causes et on a l'impression qu'il y a
une sorte d'inversion c'est aujourd'hui
il n'y a plus de lutte des classes mais
de lutte des causes ce qui amène à se
questionner sur ce fondamental
on ne se parle on ne se respecte que
s'il a démocratie va bien parce que
c'est le temps et le moment de
l'expression à côté de ça et bien je
pense qu'on a la nécessité pour y
répondre et bien de faire évoluer nos
pratiques en profondeur on a commencé on
a commencé avec notre livre blanc notre
famille politique porte dans son nom le
mot démocrate la démocratie c'est notre
ADN alors oui tout est pas parfait on va
pas se mentir pour le coup on est en
famille et c'est fait pour ça qu'en fait
la convention citoyenne c'est un début
de quelque chose qui mérite d'être
regardé d'être amélioré quand on fait le
grand débat c'est pour recréer un lien
alors est-ce que c'est parfait bien sûr
que non sauf que ça le mérite d'exister
et il faut aller chercher autre chose
hier on était un certain nombre à se
dire on sait que dans nos conseils de
quartier c'est toujours les mêmes on
n'arrive pas à les garder on sait que
dans nos associations aujourd'hui et
bien on a de moins on a de plus en plus
de mal à avoir en réalité des bénévoles
qui veulent rester dans les
responsabilités de la vie associative
alors même que quand on leur demande de
faire une action ils sont là et bien
face à ces évolutions qui nous amènent à
nous questionner sur le Conseil national
de la refondation sur la convention
citoyenne sur les conseils de quartier
sur l'engagement des jeunes quand ils
signent des pétitions
qui se passe dans le pays c'est à dire
que les gens ne tournent pas le dos à la
vie politique ils ne tourne pas le dos à
la vie en société par contre il ne croit
plus au vote
notre enjeu parce que la construction
d'une société de sa cohésion passe par
l'acceptation en réalité d'une
expression démocratique au moment même
où à une partie de notre jeunesse qui
considère que le régime démocratique et
le nôtre n'est peut-être pas finalement
un régime suffisamment important à
défendre alors aujourd'hui la démocratie
devient une cause à part entière et
quand je dis ça j'appelle votre
attention en tout cas moi je je
construis mon action sur la chaîne
nécessaire à remobiliser ce n'est pas
l'école toute seule qui réussira à
réenchanter la démocratie l'école elle
peut donner des fondamentaux elle va
donner l'éducation civique et morale
elle va donner les clés de compréhension
mais
où sont les familles où est
l'apprentissage de la démocratie et du
vote où sont ses parents qui vont
accompagner les enfants au moment où ils
vont voter ou les visites du conseil
municipal et je vais aller jusqu'au bout
où est la place en réalité des nouvelles
générations et des parcours les plus
atypiques et les plus divers dans les
associations dans les partis politiques
dans les organisations syndicales c'est
parce que il y a de moins en moins de
démocratie dans tous les lieux où nous
vivons et finalement on s'en détache
que l'Action démocratique aujourd'hui et
bien père pour une partie de notre pays
de sa valeur alors si on veut recréer
cette chaîne il faut aller chercher et
je pense c'est Patrick qui le sait il
faut aller chercher du symbole il faut
aller chercher des valeurs il faut aller
chercher de la mémoire et de l'histoire
est-ce que la démocratie est un acquis
non bien sûr que non il suffit de
regarder ce qui se passe juste à côté de
chez nous qui aurait cru il y a à peine
quelques quelques mois que aujourd'hui à
Guidel on parlerait de la guerre en
Ukraine sur notre propre continent la
négation même d'un État souverain de son
territoire
qui aurait pensé finalement que aux
élections régionales 9 jeunes sur dix ne
se sont même pas déplacés raison même
pas exprimé quelque chose ils n'ont même
pas été
et au moment où on est à la veille
d'élections syndicale on est à la veille
d'une élection en réalité européenne
dans quelques mois à la veille de la
basse de la situation politique en
Italie mais en tout cas de la bascule
que nous avons vu en Suède
je crois que il faut un électrochoc mais
si on n'est pas capable de voir que ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui est un
électrochoc suffisant pour nous tous
pour se dire il faut passer à l'action
cette action elle passe par des idées
bien sûr par l'engagement de tous bien
sûr mais
c'est notre engagement qui fera la
différence et on ne peut pas demander en
réalité un pays de se mobiliser pour
lutter contre l'abstention remettre de
la démocratie au cœur si on commence pas
par nous-mêmes nous-mêmes c'est notre
mouvement c'est notre partie c'est nos
familles c'est nos associations c'est
nos syndicats ce qui m'amène enfin à un
point qui est pour moi pour tenir mon
timing parce que je vois le temps filet
et j'ai fait la promesse à Isabelle de
le tenir
peut-être que ça va vous paraître un
petit peu cash mais vous me connaissez
on est des enfants gâtés
fondamentalement on est des enfants
gâtés de la démocratie
on sait pas tellement bagarrer pour
l'avoir on a considéré que c'était un
acquis sauf que c'est comme tout il se
trouve que un de mes collègues l'avaient
dit c'était Mohamed qui l'avait dit non
c'était Brahim je me souviens dans une
réunion Brahim Mamouche qui était notre
collègue parlementaire et l'a dit et
cette expression m'est restée la
démocratie c'est un muscle si tu ne
l'utilises pas il s'atrophie nous sommes
en train de vivre d'une certaine manière
le risque
d'atrophie de notre démocratie alors
même qu'on dit qu'est-ce qui va se
passer mais ce qui va se passer faut pas
aller chercher très loin il y a quelques
jours à peine une femme en Iran est
morte les mortes elle a perdu de sa vie
le fait de ne pas être dans un état
démocrate
aujourd'hui nous avons
nous avons la responsabilité et la
charge parce que nous sommes le
Mouvement Démocrate parce que notre
parole compte parce que nous sommes la
France et les
héritiers au-delà d'être des héritiers
des Lumières nous avons la
responsabilité de dire que oui c'était
essentiel que oui ce régime il faut le
défendre et que c'est le plus juste
parce que sinon on continuera à avoir
les extrêmes montés les radicalités
s'exprimaient ça veut dire que nos
jeunes ne se parleront plus en fait il
se taperont dessus parce qu'il ne se
comprennent plus et au milieu il y aura
des jeunes qui et plus largement dans
notre pays les gens qui ne qui
n'accepteront plus la participation à
l'impôt qui n'accepteront plus
finalement notre pacte social parce que
l'expression la condition au vivre
ensemble c'est la bonne santé d'une vie
démocratique et donc pour conclure et
pour moi c'est je pense l'essentiel
faisons que ce grand luxe qu'on a hérité
qui est un régime démocratique qui
garantit l'égalité ne tombe pas entre la
main de ceux qui veulent nous
fractionner séparer ou qu'utilisent la
colère qui font que
également s'engage que quand une cause
mais au contraire finalement que la
cause essentielle s'asseoit la cause
démocratique que quand il y a une
situation d'inégalité que tout le monde
se lève et que personne n'accepte au
profit même d'une valeur absolument
essentielle qui est celle de l'égalité
alors ne laissons pas notre pays être
gangréné par des communautarismes de
cause de thèse mais allons chercher ce
commun qui ne permettra qu'une chose à
mon avis et bien remettre de la bonne
santé et du bonheur à l'école parce
qu'il y aura un retour du respect parce
qu'on respectera à nouveau le travail du
quotidien des élus et leur abnégation
parce que quand on a une élection de en
bonne santé avec une belle mobilisation
et bien on a des organisations
syndicales qui sont fortes et
représentatives et finalement c'est le
cercle vertueux que je crois
historiquement notre partie porte par le
pluralisme par des institutions fortes
mais aussi finalement par un message
très fort et ce message en tout cas
c'est celui que je voulais je voulais
passer ce que oui nous sommes
aujourd'hui des enfants gâtés mais si on
veut le rester aujourd'hui il faut le
défendre merci Sarah
merci merci pour ton discours qui nous a
bien réveillé là tu parlais de 14h30
parfait et vibrant attachons et déjà
plein de d'expérience et donc sans
transition mais tu l'as évoqué il y a il
y a un danger il y a un danger en Europe
et on est nous sommes ravis et ravis de
t'accueillir on cherche Sandro de te
retrouver ici comme chaque année
évidemment
on a mis et en français ou Franco
européen et l'expérience tu l'as de tes
fonctions
occupées en Italie pendant le longues
années auprès de gouvernement qui était
encore
l'expression de la modération
en député européen et acte connaissance
européenne puisque tu es député européen
sur nos listes et sur les listes
Renaissance française et c'était un
honneur que de pouvoir t'avoir à nous
sur ces premières listes transnationales
quand même qu'il faut bien souligner aux
dernières élections européennes et donc
de te retrouver je sais que tu as un
timing serré puisque les députés
européens qui sont présents ici
t'attendent mais on voulait évidemment
Tentendre sur la question italienne avec
ce regard que tu as avec ce danger que
nous sentons de nouveau revenir ces
vagues d'extrémisme successifs en Italie
qui se représentent donc elle est toi
ta perception des choses et surtout les
remèdes en tout cas les perspectives que
tu nous donnes parce que les constats
nous les faisons et les dangers est
encore à nos portes voilà donc je pense
que tu as 4 minutes pour nous expliquer
tout ça mais mais en tout cas je te
laisse la parole avec plaisir autour de
nous et ravi de t'avoir auprès de Nous
merci merci encore je suis vraiment très
très content d'être à nouveau
ici avec vous à Guidel moi je les
rappelle tout le temps la première fois
que je suis venu à Guidel c'était sur
invitation d'une personne qui vous étiez
très cher qui m'était très cher que je
veux rappeler tout le temps parce que la
première fois je suis ici c'était sur
invitation de mariage de sarnet elle met
donc beaucoup et je crois qu'il vous
manque beaucoup
en 4 minutes expliquez tout ça en plus
j'ai commencé par une vision globale
donc tu vois en 4 minutes je vais
essayer une minute pour dire que la
démocratie est
en crise pas seulement en Italie pas
seulement en France elle est en crise
dans les grandes démocratie dans le
monde la démocratie est en crise aux
États-Unis dans lequel vous avez vu
l'impensable l'agression d'être un piste
au Capitole la démocratie est en crise
au Royaume-Uni et cette crise de le
développement Cathy elle est encore plus
aggravée et c'est rare encore plus
aggravé par les désastres que ils ont
choisi avec les brexits la démocratie
est mise à mal aussi en Allemagne pour
la première fois en Allemagne il y a une
coalition de 3 et je vous assure que on
la regardant un peu de l'intérieur ils
ont beaucoup plus mal que d'habitude
et
Sarah a parlé du cas français les cas
italien finalement vous savez n'est pas
très différents il y a un système
électoral qui est différent et
d'insister des solutions politiques qui
sont différentes même si il y a une
autre positive à dans ma dernière minute
mais ce qui se passe c'est
tout d'abord la démocratie est en crise
parce que on a besoin de décision
beaucoup plus rapide
la démocratie a besoin du temps
parce que
être un démocrate ça veut dire débattre
s'écouter
et on est dans un monde où les décisions
sont attendues
dans les avec les mêmes temps d'un clic
sur Twitter ou sur Facebook c'est ça le
décalage pour nous c'est un défi il faut
rendre la démocratie plus efficace
autrement évidemment les modèles
autoritaires les modèles de l'homme ou
de la femme forte dans les cas Italiens
les modèles orbaniens dans lesquels ça
suffit de gagner les élections pour tout
faire c'est ça aussi à notre défi on est
plus dans l'époque des dictatures on
n'est plus à l'époque d'Hitler et
Mussolini face aux démocratie française
au Britannique on est dans une période
où on en Europe il y a des forces de
Sein droites qui disent comme j'ai gagné
et j'ai gagné les élections j'ai pu tout
faire
je peux nier les droits des minorités je
peux nier l'état droit je peux nier la
liberté fondamentale je peux ligner les
droits d'avortement je peux nier et les
droits de la communauté LGB LGBT parce
que j'ai gagné les élections parce que
la majorité donc j'ai raison j'ai gagné
les élections donc j'ai raison c'est ça
les grands défis et c'est un défi que
nous devons aborder en Europe c'est les
grands défis qu'on nous devons aborder
évidemment en Italie donc la question de
la de l'attraction des modèles
autoritaires ou des modèles disons des
démocratie autoritaires
d'autocrate démocrate démocratique
la question de la désinformation
c'est incroyable la présence et
l'influence russe dans les débats
italiens en ce moment énorme
après on a on a des cas presque
théâtrales comme berlusconique et hier a
dit que finalement Poutine a volé
envahir qui est pour remplacer des
lignes qui avec des gens raisonnables
c'est la c'est pas une blague c'est la
déclaration qu'il a qu'il a fait hier
qu'est-ce qui se passe il se passe que
il n'y a plus de centre droit et des
centres gauche en Italie
il y a une astreinte droite et j'ai
Monique
qui
pourrait faire à 24 25% peut-être plus
et après vous avez des alliés qui sont
là pour permettre à l'extrême droite
post fasciste de fraternités
peut-être nous verrons demain d'arriver
peut-être pour la première fois dans un
pays fondateur au gouvernement parce que
ça serait la première fois dans un pays
fondateur de l'Union européenne il n'y a
pas l'extrême droite au gouvernement que
la première ministre la présidente du
conseil comme on dit Italie serait
droite donc la première question
changeons déjà le langage pour changer
la démocratie pour gagner en politique
il faut pas parler de son truc gauche et
centres droite il y a une droite extrême
dans laquelle les PP forte Italia les
alliés de républicains les alliés qui
siègent au Parlement européen avec
Bel-Ami qui nous donne toujours de
l'Essonne moi personnellement aussi et
sont là pour permettre à l'extrême
droite d'aller voir maman il les font on
le souhaite et ils les font en Italie
parce que s'il y avait pas aussi les PP
fortitas et et la Liga des salines et la
liée de l'epen avec mélonie jamais elle
pourrait avoir une majorité absolue donc
on a un défi de l'extrait droite un
autre défi des lutter contre les
ambiguïtés et contre la complicité et
contre la collaboration du PPI vis-à-vis
de l'extrême droite et ça c'est un vrai
enjeu pas seulement italien c'est un
vrai jeu européen je crois c'est un vrai
jeu aussi français
donc voilà et de l'autre côté il n'y a
plus de centre à gauche parce que s'il y
avait une chose qui on devait pas
importer mais qui est rigolait tu as
importé en Italie c'est l'anus
il est peut-être bien à donner des cours
à Sciences Po il est très mauvais à
faire de la politique
je vous l'assure donc il y a plus des
entrées gauche parce qu'il y a un parti
démocrate qui sait gaucher qui a fait
une alliance avec les alliés italiens de
Mélenchon et une alliance avec les Verts
et qui n'a aucune chance d'enlever une
voix à l'extrême droite dans la dernière
minute les les
points d'espoir donc vous devez être
très fier vous Mouvement Démocrate et
vous majorité présidentielle parce que
les seuls éléments de nouveautés
la seule force qui pourrait empêcher
d'être un droit d'avoir la majorité
absolue et en tout cas la seule force
qui sert à la véritable alternative à
l'extrême droite si elle gagnait elle
avait la majorité absolue c'est une
nouvelle alliance centrale inspirée par
les discours que j'ai entendu ici depuis
plusieurs années des François Bayroux
inspiré par les succès d'Emmanuel Macron
c'est notre allié du parti démocrates
qui a fait une alliance avec d'autres
pays
d'autres parties centrales et c'est le
seul élément du nouveauté et c'est le
seul et c'est la seule force politique
qui en réunissant des femmes et des
hommes des ministres anciens ministres
qui viennent de la droite européenne et
de la gauche européenne peut construire
l'alternative à l'extrême droite donc
vous devez être fier parce que c'est
inspiré par l'expérience du moment
démocrate c'est inspirer par Emmanuel
Macron moi je suis pas du tout
responsable pour ça évidemment j'ai rien
fait mais c'est là qu'on peut construire
et c'est une bonne nouvelle parce que ça
veut dire qu'en 2024 j'en suis sûr
en Europe aura des alliés et une
délégation italienne très importante
nombreuses avec laquelle ensemble nous
pouvons construire une alternative en
Italie et en Europe vous savez je
termine les philosophes et en politique
en you disait que quand les femmes et
les hommes ont une volonté commune leur
souffle naturellement s'harmonise alors
français italien européen harmonisant
nos souffles
[Applaudissements]
déjà mais pas que des paroles une action
et cette action européenne on doit la
préparer on a quelques mois qui vont
passer vite mais tu nous donnes cet
espoir et surtout de remettre
ce qui paraît aussi une un gage une
gageur c'est remettre les parties et
c'est notre c'est notre sens ici et
l'essence de nos journées au centre
aussi de cette construction démocratique
ce qui n'est pas simple on sent bien que
cette crise démocratique elle touche
profondément nos parties au delà même de
du système on voit bien que tout ça a
été redistribué en France aux dernières
élections et que et que tout ça fait
partie des grandes interrogations aussi
citoyennes on a la chance d'avoir autour
de nous un professeur merci Julien
celle qui vient régulièrement et qui à
l'occasion d'intervenir et je pense que
votre éclairage en tant qu' professeur
sur ces questions en tant que
chercheur et avoir écrit nombreux
ouvrages sur cette question notamment
nous éclairer d'une part sur la façon
dont vous voyez justement actuellement
cette redistribution et de la pensée et
des courants et des parties parce qu'on
voit bien que le jeu est très trouble
ces dernières élections nous l'ont
encore bien montré je pense notamment
évidemment au législatives que aussi
nous serait intéressant de pouvoir
dresser quelques pistes de réflexion sur
lequel évidemment on pourra échanger à
la suite dans dans les échanges que nous
aurons avec la salle mais en tout cas
cet œil voilà de professeur nous ferait
du bien sur cette question partisanes et
cette question de l'enjeu nous nous en
sommes convaincus nous ne serait pas là
pour ça aujourd'hui donc je vous laisse
la parole sur ce sujet merci d'être là
merci beaucoup et merci pour votre
invitation bonjour à toutes et à tous
avant de dire quoi que ce soit qui
pourrait être utile à votre débat je
voulais vous dire que j'étais très
heureux d'être dans un parti politique
justement aujourd'hui parce que ils ont
un rôle fondamental pour faire vivre et
revivre et renaître aussi la démocratie
et je voulais juste souligner que
j'avais beaucoup de respect pour les
adhérents et les militants des partis
politiques ils ont un rôle difficile
parfois un rôle décrié et je pense que
la crise n'est pas de leur fait la crise
est liée sans doute au fait que il y en
a pas assez mais voilà le rôle est
fondamental je trouve qu'on parle pas
bien de très souvent dans la presse ou
ailleurs alors je vais essayer de
répondre à vos questions en 4 minutes
mais je voudrais partir de du Livre
blanc que vous avez fait que j'ai lu
avec attention qui est parfait mais je
veux pas jouer le professeur mais il est
parfait je n'ai rien à dire rien à très
bonne note
non non mais parce que c'est aussi des
questions qu'on se pose quand on étudie
ce qu'on appelle la sociologie
électorale et vous êtes très centré sur
le vote la démocratie représentative et
vous faites des propositions qui peuvent
avoir de vrais effets donc je voudrais
apporter faire un petit pas de côté pour
faire la suite de votre livre blanc
puisque j'avais été auditionné
d'ailleurs après ce propos là donc
effectivement le vote est en crise vous
avez montré que il y avait un problème
de participation un problème de mal
inscription et vous vous cherchez à
résoudre ça c'est c'est un phénomène
important majeur surtout chez les jeunes
et puis j'ai envie d'ajouter il y a de
la désacri désacralisation du vote
originellement 1848 quand on établit
suffrage universel masculin on met en
place tout un catéchisme républicain
pour dire qu'il faut voter que voter
c'est vertueux donc on joue beaucoup sur
la corde morale et pour être à l'époque
un gentilhomme il faut voter je pense
que cette sacralisation qui est
complètement en panne ne peut repartir
qu'avec d'autres arguments que la
vieille morale qui était très bonne et
très juste à l'époque de la Troisième
République mais quand on regarde aussi
d'autres d'autres résultats on voit que
effectivement il y a des taux
d'abstention croissants alors les taux
d'abstention varient aussi sont
l'intensité de la campagne selon la
qualité de l'offre et puis ce qui se
passe en termes de médiatisation on voit
également que si les jeunes votent
beaucoup moins que les autres une fois
qu'il travaille qu'il rentre dans leur
vie de famille il vote comme les autres
bon donc c'est aussi lié à des moments
particuliers de de la jeunesse et puis
j'ai envie d'ajouter que à l'exception
d'une petite proportion tout le monde
vote au moins une ou deux fois dans sa
vie en fait donc il y a du vote
intermittent mais il y a on peut pas
dire qu'il y a pas de vote mais je dis
pas que c'est magnifique c'est
merveilleux et vous avez raison de vous
de vous en inquiéter alors le petit pas
de côté que je voulais vous proposer
vous dire aussi cette démocratie
représentative pour tout un tas de
raisons peut-être vu comme étant en
crise même si ça fait 30 ans qu'on dit
que c'est une crise en général quand ça
fait 30 ans que c'est une crise c'est un
peu plus structurel que conjoncturel
mais il y a aussi d'autres champs de
notre société civile qui
se sont institutionnalisés développés
donc automatiquement on pense à celui de
la démocratie participative et moi ce
que j'ai en tête c'est que effectivement
si ça va te pas beaucoup ce que je vois
dans les travaux c'est que on
n'interpelle pas moins les responsables
politiques on va pas moins au contact
des responsables politiques j'ai il y a
pas très longtemps comme un livre sur
les courriers qu'on adresse au président
de la République et puis j'ai essayé de
regarder tous les travaux qui portaient
sur des courriers qu'on adressé aux élus
alors il y a pas beaucoup de travaux
justement sur la science politique ça
n'a pas beaucoup intéressé aux
États-Unis un peu plus parce qu'aux
États-Unis un petit secteur qu'on
appelle le champ de la sociologie du
contact team c'est regarder
quels sont les points de contact entre
les représentés et les représentants et
quand on regarde cet univers là donc
effectivement on a en une demi-heure ça
va pas beaucoup mais il y a jamais eu de
contact d'interpellation entre
citoyennes citoyens et je pense que
quand on fait le bilan et vous le faites
très justement il faut avoir à l'esprit
tout ce spectre des rapports politiques
des formes de participation aux
politiques donc tout à l'heure j'étais
en voiture avec deux experts des
transitions écologiques qui me parlait
de leur univers vous allez pouvoir les
écouter dans pas longtemps dans des
ateliers c'est c'est par exemple un
univers truffé d'innovation de
mobilisation de portage de cause
d'influenceurs donc il y a ce problème
du vote il faudra peut-être le
retravailler mais il y a aussi
parallèlement des choses qui s'invente
alors je pense que le rôle des partis
politiques c'est pas beau ce que je veux
dire c'est de mettre un peu d'ordre
voilà c'est c'est d'essayer de
domestiquer aussi ce qu'on appelle la
démocratie sauvage qui a son utilité
mais qui doit sans doute passer par les
tamis des partis politiques pour que
pour que tout concorde les démocraties
représentatives et participatives et
puis peut-être qu'on aura l'occasion
parler mais je me suis dit je vais pas
venir si j'ai absolument aucune
proposition à faire parce que vous êtes
là quand même pour trouver des
propositions même si c'est vrai que les
responsables politiques les élus les
militants bien meilleures idées que les
profs de Sciences Po ça c'est vrai
j'avais fait une étude c'est les plus
mauvais en politique c'est des loosers
en politique donc c'est pour ça que je
fais pas de politique c'est que je sais
d'avance que je suis avec lui voilà donc
chacun son boulot mais c'est vrai que je
me suis penché sur l'enseignement moral
et cylique parce que j'ai d'une très
belle thèse qui porte tout de suite qui
en fait l'évaluation et je me dis il y a
pas que ça je me dis que dedans il y a
sans doute des choses à faire parfois ça
marche sous conditions parce que je
pense que la fibre dans l'engagement la
fibre de la citoyenneté ça va être mes
derniers mots c'est souvent quelque
chose dont on hérite moi si je suis là
c'est pas par hasard c'est parce que il
y a des ancêtres etc et qui d'ailleurs
ont appartenu à vos ancêtres
idéologiques c'est donc voilà soit on
hérite de sa citoyenneté en quelque
sorte je sais que c'est des droits mais
soit soit on l'apprend voilà et comment
on l'apprend quand on en a pas hérité
quoi que ce soit je pense c'est à mon
avis c'est une question importante merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
je pense qu'on aura l'occasion de
poursuivre mes
ça me permet de donner la parole à
Élodie shaker la forge qui est député de
l'Isère qui est vice-présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale félicitations à
toi Elodie et qui dans sa carrière
professionnelle a eu l'occasion de
travailler sur un certain nombre de
sujets auprès de personnes imminentes
dont évidemment Jacqueline gourou permet
de citer et et de par rapport à ce que
vous venez de dire Julien
expérimente et on a travaillé pendant
cinq ans sur justement cette question de
la représentativité qui nous tient à
cœur sur lequel tu as beaucoup travaillé
et donc je te laisse dire ce qui te
tient à cœur sur ce sujet et dire aussi
combien beaucoup de choses déjà sont
faites et qui maintenant il est temps de
utiliser peut-être merci beaucoup
Isabelle alors effectivement beaucoup de
solutions étaient faites alors je suis
très contente d'apprendre que notre
livret Blanc avait une bonne note je
vous remercie monsieur le professeur
parce que c'est vrai que c'est important
aussi d'avoir ce regard de l'extérieur
et c'est un en plus c'était une méthode
de travail un peu on va dire
avant-gardiste puisqu'on avait des
parlementaires on avait des élus locaux
on avait des militants et et c'était ce
croisement de regard là qui je crois
avait permis sous la houlette de
Jean-Noël Barraud d'arriver à produire
un éventail de solutions qui allait
voilà tous dans le même sens c'était
comment est-ce qu'on peut permettre de
réduire l'abstention alors beaucoup de
choses ont été faites beaucoup de
solutions ont été proposées là vous
venez d'évoquer comment est-ce qu'on
hérite de sa citoyenneté je trouve ça
assez voilà assez fantastique comme
comme débat parce que du coup on pense
voilà à ses parents et on se dit bah
qu'est-ce qu'ils nous ont transmis voilà
quand là je vais vous faire un aveu mais
on est entre nous mon père n'a jamais
voté
voilà donc je vous pose ça là donc moi
je suis là par contre donc comme quoi
finalement on hérite aussi de ce qu'on
veut hériter et on peut prendre le
contre-pied de son héritage donc on est
ici tous ensemble aujourd'hui et la
question qui nous est posée c'est
peut-on encore faire société alors si je
suis là c'est que bien évidemment que
j'y crois qu'on peut encore faire
société
alors moi ce que ce que j'aimerais ce
dont j'aimerais vous parler et puis on
échangera bien évidemment suite c'est
bien évidemment les dernières élections
parce que voilà on a perdu des des
camarades des amis on a perdu des
pointures aussi Isabelle Patrick enfin
tous ceux qui sont qui sont là
et on a une nouvelle Assemblée
totalement
recomposée et ce qui me fait dit aussi
que on l'a vu avec la crise covid on l'a
vu avec les dernières crises qu'on a pu
vivre puisque finalement la vie n'est
qu'une succession de crise que
finalement déjà notre Constitution
résistait que nos institutions qui
commencent à être un petit peu voilà
ancienne résiste quand même donc c'est
quand même les notes positives que je
voulais partager avec vous cet
après-midi
donc ça résiste
et on a une Assemblée nationale vous
n'êtes pas sans le savoir qui est
totalement
recomposée avec
déséquilibre voilà vous le savez on a
une majorité relative on a des extrêmes
très renforcés
un éclatement aussi on a parlé des
parties politiques un éclatement des
groupes politiques
et finalement
et bien on se dit que c'est assez
représentatif de la France telle qu'elle
est aujourd'hui
et on pourrait peut-être voir
l'Assemblée nationale comme un petit
laboratoire alors je suis depuis
quelques semaines au perchoir avec une
vue voilà un peu plus
panoramique que celle que j'avais avant
je quitte les rangs du modèle
sympathiques
amicaux confortable parfois
pour me retrouver
sur ce perchoir et de là effectivement
la vue change et est-ce qu'on va réussir
et on a déjà prouvé qu'on avait réussi
sur les textes qui sont arrivés à
travailler est-ce qu'on va réussir à
s'écouter est-ce qu'on va réussir à
faire ce pourquoi moi je crois que les
Français nous ont élus c'est à dire à
travailler à produire des lois qui
soient utiles à nos concitoyens en tout
cas c'est ce à quoi moi j'aspire donc on
a cette responsabilité là c'est une
responsabilité qui est collective qui
est partagée parce que quand on voit
effectivement nos amis italiens et ce
qui voilà ce qui risque d'arriver demain
bien évidemment voilà c'est pas le
chemin que nous souhaitons prendre
c'est évident
et bien ça ça renforce la pression que
nous avons et à l'Assemblée et j'imagine
aussi au gouvernement pour pour pouvoir
trouver un chemin
cette voie qui nous arrivera à retisser
et on n'est pas au Mouvement Démocrate
pour rien puisque ça a été rappelé hier
un pays rien ne lui résiste et je crois
que c'est vraiment cette volonté là qui
au quotidien nous anime chacun et
chacune d'entre nous alors l'anneau on
est sur la voilà sur l'estrade
aujourd'hui mais vous êtes chacune et
chacun des ambassadeurs de ce message là
on a cette capacité on en parlait ce
matin à l'atelier 133 on a cette
capacité à écouter à dialoguer et à
accepter que les autres ne soient pas
d'accord avec nous
on est en capacité de comprendre leur
cheminement on est en capacité de faire
ce lien ce dialogue et même si c'est
peut-être trop ambitieux mais en tout
cas j'ai envie d'être ambitieuse pour
notre pays qu'on arrive alors je sais
pas où j'en suis dans mes minutes mais
c'est pas grave
qu'on arrive à retisser ce lien et et
arriver à vraiment construire cette
société à laquelle on participe tous
cette Europe dans laquelle on a envie
d'être heureux et dans ce monde qui oui
bouge oui nous inquiète
mais finalement qui nous qui est notre
notre volonté d'arriver à retisser et à
construire cette cette fameuse société
merci Élodie
merci parce que effectivement tu as
prononcé les mots qui nous tiennent
aussi à cœur
dans notre mouvement c'est la question
du dialogue c'est la question du travail
avec les élus c'est la question du
travail avec les ce qu'on appelle des
partenaires sociaux qui sont finalement
eux-mêmes des élus des représentants des
personnes voilà qui qui sont dans le
dialogue et ça nous tient à coeur ça
nous tient à coeur on le sait très bien
à chacun d'entre vous pour chacun
d'entre vous dans ce que vous faites
dans vos territoires lorsque vous faites
dans vos actions qu'elles soient
associatives syndicales ou au sein de
vos collectivités et Patrick s'en
profite pour te donner la parole après
ce premier tour de table pour te
présenter oui évidemment dans tes
nouvelles fonctions
donc ancien député de Haute-Savoie qui
ne le sait pas ancien président de notre
groupe de savoir excuse-moi waouh alors
ça part mal
[Rires]
donc surtout enfin ce qui nous a animé
pendant trois ans et demi c'est à
formidable président de notre groupe
démocrate de modem devenus démocrate et
apparentés et qui assume nous porter et
et nous faire vivre une belle une belle
mandature après après Marc et à nos
côtés et donc aussi
et c'est là tes anciennes fonctions
puisque tu as été une vingtaine d'années
maire de savoir d'une commune de Savoie
rasoir c'est bon la ravoir
la ravoir voilà surtout vice-président
après avoir été conseillé départemental
vice-président du conseil régional
Rhône-Alpes sur les questions éminentes
des transports c'est justement par
rapport à ces expériences ton expérience
quel est le rôle maintenant enfin en
tout cas on en a commencé à aborder le
sujet des hier soir entre nous la place
le rôle des élus locaux dans toute cette
ces bouleversements ce que vous venez
tous de décrire mais qui nous tient à
cœur dans ce mouvant et j'aimerais que
que tu nous tu nous donnes un petit peu
d'espoir peut-être ou nous donne
quelques pistes de ta pensée sur sur le
sujet
merci beaucoup Isabelle
et puis merci pour tes mots qui sont
très sympathiques
moi je vais vous dire que j'ai beaucoup
d'optimisme au fond comme vous parce que
vous avez décrit une situation qui est
inquiétante qui est dangereuse mais dont
on peut sortir simplement on va avoir du
boulot il y a du boulot pour chacune et
chacun d'entre nous
parce qu'on est effectivement
percuté
fortement par beaucoup d'évolution de
sociétés
on a des institutions qui sont fortes
dans ce pays mais qui malheureusement
n'exerce pas leur force comme elle le
devrait
on le sait alors n'étant plus député je
peux me lâcher un peu
j'ai eu à connaître
dans le quinquennat qui vient de
s'écouler mais il y a encore quelques
mois
des décisions de conseil
constitutionnels alors j'espère que
Jacqueline va pouvoir mettre un peu
d'ordre dans tout ça mais qui était plus
sur le fait de l'opportunité que de la
constitutionnalité j'ai eu à connaître
des décisions du Conseil d'État parfois
à la place du gouvernement ça
j'ai eu à connaître un gouvernement qui
faisait la loi à la place du Parlement
tentez si bien qu'il serait même en gros
il restait plus au parlementaire que le
droit d'amander alors que normalement il
faisait la loi et si j'ai bien compris
le gouvernement aurait même pu s'ils
font sommeil Roux était pas intervenus
avoir pour projet non pas de faire la
loi mais de faire aussi les amendements
donc on voit bien qu'il y a des formes
de dérèglement on voit le la même
difficulté tu le disais très bien
Isabelle avec les élus locaux parce que
effectivement moi je les défendrai
toujours pour avoir été l'un d'eux
mais il y a beaucoup d'inquiétudes
quand des mers sont élus personnalités
préférées des Français sont élus à 40%
de participation des présidents de
région qui se prennent tous pour les
présidents de la République de leur
région qui sont élus avec 30% de
participation
on peut pas d'un revers de la main dire
bah finalement les institutions
fonctionnent pas très bien on va confier
ça une nouvelle décentralisation parce
qu'en réalité le délitement de la
confiance
ce dérèglement général des institutions
il vaut à tous les étages et puis les
partis politiques sont pas exemple n'en
parlait avec Bruno à l'instant
et nous aussi il faut évidemment que on
se remette en cause enfin quand on
regarde Sandro tu disais bien sans trop
droit et centre gauche en Italie enfin
la droite modérée et la gauche modérée
en France c'est la même chose
c'est aussi le grand dérèglement enfin
quand le PS est capable de renoncer au
nucléaire à l'Europe et de ne rien dire
quand la nuit pèse
allait je veux pas dire qu'il dit du
bien mais en tout cas détourne le regard
sur ce qu'a fait poutine au mois de
février dernier
et quand on regarde à droite qui aurait
imaginé il y a encore quelques années
que Bruno Retailleau soit présenté comme
l'alternative modérée d'érection
donc je crains qu'on soit percuté par
beaucoup de dérèglements et là il y a
pas besoin de grande réforme pour le
coup
il faut simplement qu'on se remette la
tête à l'endroit et que chacun rejoue
son rôle que chacun reprenne sa
responsabilité entre les trois pouvoirs
et puis qu'on fasse attention à ce que
le suis qu'on présente comme le
quatrième le pouvoir médiatique mais en
fait plus globalement le pouvoir des
réseaux sociaux le pouvoir de ces
nouveaux échanges vous le disiez très
bien professeur à l'instant
l'effet que ça a produit on peut tous se
plaindre qu'effectivement on vive avec
l'algorithme Facebook et qu'au fond
chacun soit
uniquement nourri chaque jour de ce
qu'il a envie d'entendre dire on l'a
tous vécu d'ailleurs on a vécu à la fin
des gilets jaunes via le début des
gilets jaunes il y avait quelque chose
de légitime dire à être mieux reconnu et
mieux payé par la société mais la fin
des gilets jaunes il restait plus grand
chose mais il restait quatre personnes
sur un rond-point ils étaient absolument
persuadés d'être majoritaire dans le
pays parce que l'information qu'il
voyait sur leur smartphone c'était une
information où finalement tous les gens
pensaient la même chose que et donc ils
étaient absolument aujourd'hui ils
étaient mieux que majorité ils étaient
quasiment à l'unanimité dans le pays
mais il faut pas s'en pour autant ça
fait partie de notre vie il faut
simplement que les parlementaires
décident de ne pas se couper les mains
et les bras en s'interdisant par exemple
de d'acheter de l'algorithme Facebook
lorsqu'ils font des campagnes
électorales les Russes sont tous les
jours en train de faire campagne contre
nous pour faire monter l'extrême droite
et prendre le pouvoir grâce aux réseaux
sociaux et lorsqu'on fait une campagne
électorale on a même pas le droit
d'acheter 5 minutes de présent sur
Facebook il faut qu'on soit capable de
travailler aussi avec les médias
modernes rappelez-vous il y a quelques
années je rappelle souvent cet exemple
le la discussion sur le Sénat qui devait
être mis en cause éventuellement on
aurait pu se débarrasser mauvaise idée
madame la sénatrice or bien
hérissent en France a été sauvé à la
fois parce qu'il y avait des sénatrices
et des sénateurs qui s'appellent
défendre mais c'est surtout parce qu'ils
ont fait Public Sénat qu'ils ont été
capables de faire de la télé et donc un
parti politique comme nous il faut qu'on
soit capable aussi d'avoir une présence
sur tous ces nouveaux médias sans
[Musique]
angélisme mais au contraire en sachant
les utiliser puis je crois qu'il y a une
troisième chose entre des règlements
institutionnels et nouvelles vie
médiatique parce que la politique ne
vivent dans les médias c'est qu'il faut
oser parler des sujets tabous
et je pense que s'il y a une crise
démocratique et une crise des partis
politiques et une crise des élus c'est
parce que de temps en temps il y a des
sujets qu'on s'interdit et quand ils ne
sont plus évoqués que par les extrêmes
bah forcément c'est les extrêmes qui
attirent vers eux le l'électorat et de
ce point de vue là moi j'ai beaucoup
aimé que François je lui ai dit cette
semaine
réévoque le sujet de l'immigration
débats qu'on pouvait jamais aborder dans
notre pays sauf à être traité
d'extrémisme
être capable avec des mots choisis de
dire que les peuples
ont droit de disposer de leur identité
et que dans le moment incertain qu'on
vit dans le monde et sur notre continent
et avec le risque migratoires de
migration économiques mais aussi de
migration climatiques demain et on vit
les migrations liées à la guerre qu'on
soit capable de réfléchir à ces sujets
là de façon sereine et que ce soit pas
seulement les autres qui s'en saisissent
je pense que c'est extrêmement important
ça vaut aussi pour la délinquance
c'est même si on a une bonne note au
Livre Blanc vous avez constaté
qu'effectivement certains d'entre nous
sont pas passés en deuxième année il y a
quand ils sont pas passés en deuxième
année souvent
en discutant avec eux on s'est rendu
compte que c'était parce qu'on avait
fait du déni au moment du Stade de
France
au Stade de France qu'est ce qu'on a
vécu pendant les élections législatives
bah une image d'une certaine délinquance
qui existe dans ce pays et parce que le
ministre de l'Intérieur a voulu la nier
et ben certains nombre de parlementaires
sont restés sur le carreau donc il faut
pas qu'on soit dans le dernier ni sûr
des sujets d'immigration ni sur des
sujets de délinquance puis un troisième
sujet qui a un mot tabou parce qu'en
France on en parle jamais c'est la
question de l'argent dans tes si bien
que aujourd'hui on parle de pouvoir
d'achat alors on a on se représente le
pouvoir d'achat comme le gouvernement
qui va nous donner un chèque de plus ou
qui va nous apporter une subvention de
plus ou une aide de plus la réalité
c'est qu'il faut juste qu'on arrive à
parler du partage de la valeur
et de se dire que quand des entreprises
font des profits avant de savoir si on
peut les taxer faut savoir comment elles
peuvent les partager et donc je crois
que si on est capable de refaire
fonctionner les institutions
convenablement si on est capable de
s'adresser aux médias et aux nouveaux
médias tels qu'ils existent et si enfin
on parle aux gens des sujets qui les
intéressent au lieu de polémiquer sur la
surface des choses peut-être que on va
redresser un peu la démocratie
[Applaudissements]
merci Patrick je te laisse la parole
avant une minute parce qu'il y a des
forums députés européens dont je dois
vous quitter mais pourrai prendre deux
points que je trouve extrêmement
important de ce qui est Patrick disait
les premiers c'est que il y a un bloc
social d'un autre société et pour moi de
ce point de vue l'Italie la France
entrait similaire ce qui finalement
c'est qu'il s'est passé en Italie en
2018 c'était une alliance du
rassemblement national et de la nuque
dans un système qui n'est pas
présidentiel mais qui est par la menteur
s'il n'y avait pas les impressions en
France je vois pas trop de différence
donc il y a des éléments communs dans
nos sociétés parce qu'ils ont les débats
c'est des territorialisé sont les mêmes
débats dans nos sociétés et les premiers
débats c'est exactement des tournées les
dos aux questions qui a préoccupent et
inquiète énormément nos citoyens
donc il a tout à fait raison Patrick on
peut pas laisser la question de
l'immigration la question de la sécurité
la question des inquiétudes pour
l'avenir de pas mal des parties de notre
société aux extrêmes parce que il y a un
bloc social qui va voter attention il y
a pas mal d'abstention mais il y a un
bloc social dans l'espérance italienne
pourquoi chaque élection il y a une
force extrémiste qui fait un exploit
exceptionnel parce qu'il y a un bloc
social du 20% des électorats des
électeurs qui comme faute des réponses
en ayant l'impression d'être totalement
négligée en disant on est invisible pour
la politique on est invisible donc ils
vont une fois sur les 5 étoiles une fois
chez sa vie des rallier de Marine Le Pen
cette fois-ci ils semblait avec Mélodie
mais là il y avait 5 % il va faire 25 %.
quel hasard c'est bon et je crois que
c'est un peu la même chose en France si
on regarde aussi même les passages et
entre l'extrême droite et l'extrême
gauche dans les arguments dans les
thèmes et aussi un peu de relectorat
donc là on a un débat commun dernier le
deuxième point comme je suis un de vos
députés
on est en train de travailler pour
régler la réglée commencez à aborder la
question donc Patrick va parler parce
que dans les réseaux sociaux c'est les
Far West les Russes font des
informations nous ne faisons rien je
suis rapporteur pour une nouvelle loi
européenne sur la publicité politique
pour avoir un minimum en sorte de normes
communs avec plus de transparence et
avec en ayant la possibilité nous aussi
de faire notre bataille dans le respect
des règles sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
absolument fondamental parce que faut
tes règles faut approche commune des
Russes ils ont et nous les subissons
voilà merci
merci beaucoup va rejoindre on te laisse
avec tes collègues
Sarah je voudrais être redonner la
parole
parce que justement ce qui est évoqué
alors il y a une question il y a je
voudrais aussi l'élargir il y a une
question qui nous est arrivée sur qui
rejoint la question que je voulais vous
poser tout ça plus largement puisque la
question de l'abstention elle rejoint
après la question et elle pose la
question de la légitimité et plus
largement de la participation évidemment
et des solutions comme tu l'as évoqué je
sais que tu y travailles au sein de ton
ministère mais il y a une question qui
est arrivée et qui me semble aussi tout
à fait intéressante parce qu'elle pose
la question aussi de la légitimité c'est
Alain qui est nantais et qui nous dit la
haute fonction publique de par sa
présence au long terme au sommet de
l'État ne finit-elle pas par usurper le
pouvoir assez légitime dépositaire que
sont les élus et l'exécutif nommé et
surtout je dirais les élus mais ils sont
avant tout élu voilà
et là
mais mais cette question on y a
travaillé on s'est battu dessus et on se
bat de sur ces questions et François le
dire régulièrement c'est cette question
de la présence moi je crois qu'Emmanuel
Macron il y a une discours clair en 2017
en 2016 et 2017 son livre et il y a
quelques pages du livre on y avait
travaillé il y avait quand même des
sujets est-ce qu'on a répondu
complètement bien sûr que non bien sûr
que non est-ce qu'on a essayé oui mais
voilà j'aimerais vous entendre sur ces
sujets rapidement parce que il nous
reste 16 minutes 50 pour encore vous
laisser la parole donc n'hésitez pas à
vous poser question mais Sarah toi qui
est maintenant au sein de l'exécutif
comment tu tu vois les choses sur ce
sujet de manière très claire et très
transparente parce qu'on est en famille
évidemment évidemment qu'il y a de la
reproduction sociale au sein des
institutions évidemment qu'elle a
puissance des corps maintenant la
réalité c'est que c'est pas nouveau que
François l'avait écrit dans un de ces
livres en 2009 entre autres dans la but
de pouvoir et que c'est pas pour rien
qu'il avait déjà dit maintenant moi
quand je vois aussi dans cette fonction
publique parfois des hommes et des
femmes de bonne volonté qui ont envie
mais qui parfois sont pris dans une
sorte de de maillon de chaîne qui est
difficile mais notre responsabilité à
nous c'est d'être exemplaire et quand je
dis exemplaire ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que quand on est du Mouvement
Démocrate et que on intègre un exécutif
parce que notre famille politique parce
que François bayeron a mené un certain
nombre de combats et qu'on a la chance
de représenter nos valeurs et nos
pratiques à nous d'être les premiers
exemplaires dans le choix de nos
cabinets dans la manière dont on a une
relation avec nos administrations c'est
quand même de c'est plutôt de notoriété
publique au sens administratif du terme
mais j'ai été moi en désaccord avec mon
administration centrale et bien j'ai
fait le choix de changer la direction de
l'administration centrale est-ce que
c'est facile non
est-ce qu'il faut être courageux oui
est-ce que c'est long oui mais sauf que
quand tu le fais et bien tu avances et
ça m'amène à un autre point et je sais
que vous êtes un certain nombre ici
à le savoir mais je pense que c'est
important aussi de le rappeler nous on
arrive à le faire aujourd'hui parce que
avant nous il y avait pour le coup
François qui avait déjà bousculé et moi
dans la maison dans laquelle je suis je
dirais au sein de l'éducation nationale
ça reste il se trouve que François était
un des premiers ministres de l'Éducation
nationale à avoir nommé une directrice
de cabinet qui n'était pas de ses corps
et évidemment on la connaît dans notre
maison c'était Marielle et bien c'est
aussi en posant des actes comme ça qui
sont des actes fondamentaux des actes
forts que oui on va récupérer ce pouvoir
légitime alors à nous de faire à nous de
transformer et puis au-delà de ça plus
en profondeur parce que parce que moi je
suis fière de nos actions en fait et je
suis fière de l'héritage quel autre et
bien le président de la République est
en train avec le Ministre en charge
évidemment de la fonction publique en
train de transformer les corps en train
de rendre de transformer l'ENA en train
de ramener des prépas pour la haute
fonction publique sur nos territoires il
se trouve que Geneviève a apporté entre
autres une prépa que j'ai visité mais
que je trouve génial c'est une prépa qui
est portée par la gendarmerie nationale
d'égalité des chances la plus complète
on n'a pas tous la chance d'aller en
prépa quand on sort du bac voilà parce
que nos parents parce que notre culture
parce que notre patrimoine culturel
n'est pas n'est pas identique sauf que
au bout de trois ans au bout de quatre
ans au bout d'un master quand on galère
à rentrer sur le marché du travail et
qu'on a l'énergie peut-être à ce
moment-là l'envie de d'aller chercher de
la peut-être un concours de haute
fonction publique parce que c'est plus
juste parce qu'on a envie de s'engager
pour son pays
il y a plus de prépa c'est impression
que c'est trop tard et ben si
aujourd'hui il y a des opportunités
prépa talent on reconnaît le fait que à
23 24 25 ans on a besoin d'une petite
solde alors la gendarmerie verse 1000
euros par mois mais elle te loge à Paris
parce que tout le monde n'a pas accès un
logement à Paris c'est trop cher elle te
donne le moyen de de
déplacer avec un passe Navigo oui elle
reconnaît ta situation familiale mais
elle permet à une vingtaine de jeunes
alors ça c'est partout ça va être
développé par tout en France mais elle
permet une vingtaine de jeunes qui n'ont
pas eu la chance de faire la prépa
post-bac finalement d'avoir la chance
d'intégrer ses plus hautes fonctions qui
sont les fonctions de l'État mais moi je
crois que on aura gagné cette bataille
que quand on arrêtera de juger ceux qui
sont dans la fonction publique et ceux
qui sont dans le privé et qu'on
permettra des allers-retours parce que
moi je ne me fais pas au débat qu'on a
eu à la rentrée
et pour conclure ce débat il est simple
on a tous à porter quelque chose
l'intérêt général on le porte en étant
dans le privé en étant dans le public si
on avait des allers-retours beaucoup
plus simple beaucoup plus humains et
beaucoup plus accompagné alors en fait
notre administration nos collectivités
iraient mieux et pour conclure parce que
c'était la rentrée scolaire vous avez
tous vu le débat sur les contractuels
et bien moi je moi j'ai trouvé ça un
dessin et je vous le dis simplement ce
sont des hommes et des femmes qui
viennent accompagner plus de 850 000
personnes qui font partie de l'éducation
nationale qui sont des enseignants de
formation alors il y a de la bonne
volonté moi je pense que toutes les
bonnes volontés sont bien à prendre si
elle est accompagnée si elle est formée
et quand c'est ta fille ou ton fusquait
dans une de ses classes tu as envie que
finalement il est le meilleur
enseignement mais on sait dans cette
maison dans notre famille politique à
quel point on juge pas finalement que
les parcours mais les actes c'est pas ça
la promesse de la République bien sûr
que si alors à nous aussi de transformer
ces regards et de permettre ces
allers-retours avec bienveillance et je
crois que c'est la signature de notre de
notre famille
vous voulez dire aussi du mal des
fonctionnaires
tu as habilement répondu c'est quand
même elle est quand même très forte
parce que quand on a mis du gouvernement
vous avez pas un problème avec le
fonctionnaire ah bah si quand même un
peu voyez c'est bon
c'est quand même une grande chance faut
se le dire entre nous ce que je pense
qu'on est parti responsable d'avoir une
fonction publique à une autre fonction
publique de grand talent et pour avoir
vécu la période covid où il y a eu des
choses bien faites des choses moins bien
faites le fait d'avoir pu s'appuyer sur
cette armature là avec des jantes
talentueux
incontestablement ça a été une chance
pour le pays alors après évidemment on
peut considérer que de temps en temps
ils prennent un peu trop le pouvoir par
rapport aux politiques il faut que le
politique soit fort et c'est tout
l'enjeu de sa légitimité démocratique
dire plus à votre a plus il y aura de la
participation et plus le politique
pourra diriger à son administration faut
simplement veiller à ce que
les bonnes régulations et que par
exemple un ministre est le droit de
choisir son directeur de cabinet et qui
soit pas choisi par ailleurs et que
ministre puisse
décider des nominations de son ressort
plutôt que les nominations soient
décidées ailleurs voilà la bonne
entendeur
une question une question qui est
arrivée dans la salle qui nous replonge
sur la question de la participation
électorale c'est le vol d'ici un endroit
à défendre ou un devoir à accomplir donc
là je me tourne vers
notre spécialiste donc Julien il nous
dit j'aimerais votre avis sur le sujet
je dirais les deux
[Rires]
non non c'est une vraie c'est à dire que
pour moi les droits et les devoirs sont
les deux facettes d'une même pièce
c'est pas une fausse réponse que je vous
fais ou je bosse pas je bottes pas en
touche mais j'en suis j'en suis
convaincu
et on le voit bien finalement ces
escadies c'est ce qu'a dit ça dans dans
l'actualité
aujourd'hui
finalement oui nous sommes des enfants
gâtés et encore plus alors tu es
beaucoup plus jeune que moi mais notre
génération on va dire c'est voilà pour
être
effectivement on découvre finalement ce
que c'est que d'avoir la guerre à
quelques voilà 2000 km de chez nous
c'est une découverte donc est-ce que le
vote est un droit défendre oui bien
évidemment à ce titre là je pense que
peut-être qu'aujourd'hui on en a plus
conscience et ensuite le devoir
accomplir donc là ça va me permettre de
faire la transition vers le professeur
qui est à ma droite sur ce devoir là
effectivement si soit on a été avec ses
parents
dans la mairie ou l'école ou le gymnase
où on a finalement été initié à ses
gestes civique qui sont de prendre le
temps le dimanche en plus d'aller voter
d'aller se déplacer dans un dans un
bureau de vote ou finalement et bien on
sa culture soi-même et comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le mettre en place alors
dans ce fameux livret blanc on avait
cette volonté aussi de moderniser le
vote de façon vraiment concrète
on en a parlé à plusieurs reprises ici
mais le vote électronique le vote par
correspondance le fait qu'il puisse être
ouvert de façon plus large le fait qu'on
puisse le faire peut-être même en drive
enfin bon c'est des des choses qui ont
été qui ont été abordées c'est vrai que
à ce stade
ça a été un nom n o n en lettres
capitales administration merci Isabelle
de me faire la transition et suivez mon
regard le bureau des élections du
ministère de l'intérieur ou notamment
sur la question des machines à voter
mais je ne remettrai pas une pièce sur
les machines à voter
on voit bien que le moratoire est bien
sur les machines à voter en fait il est
justifié par aucun texte donc ça nous
fait un petit peu aussi le lien avec la
précédente la précédente question qui
est de dire qu'à un moment donné la
volonté politique
quand elle est là et bien parfois elle
doit aussi être utilisée à faire bouger
l'administration la haute fonction
publique qui voilà dit que par exemple
scrutin municipal il est tel qu'il est
depuis 1884 pourquoi est-ce qu'il
changerait et finalement oui mais
monsieur dame pourquoi est-ce qu'il
changerait puisqu'il est là depuis 1894
voilà donc allons nous restait en 1884
je passe enfin je me permets je veux pas
piquer ta place Isabelle Julien
aujourd'hui
avec une session très sciences pour
Grandin c'est un droit et puis on fait
la synthèse alors moi j'ai envie de je
vais prendre le la question sérieusement
je veux dire que c'est je le penser
comme un droit en fait et pas comme un
devoir parce que tout à l'heure j'ai dit
qu'il y a eu une désacralisation à
l'origine par nos catéchisme
républicains on faisait des grandes
leçons de morale pour dire que si vous
votez pas vous êtes de mauvaises
personnes en fait et ça ça peut plus
marcher et puis je pense que on entend
mieux aujourd'hui l'idée que le vote
c'est un droit qui permet d'accéder qui
permet d'avoir du pouvoir qui permet
d'avoir prise sur le rêve plutôt que
vous serez vertueux si vous votez et
c'est pour ça que tout à l'heure j'ai
dit soit on en est rite ou alors on
bénéficie aussi d'une de territoire plus
ou moins politisés qui nous font croiser
des militants des associations c'est
très important d'où le rôle des partis
politiques ou alors effectivement ça
s'apprend et on penchant sur
l'enseignement moral et si c'est pas
rien cet enseignement parce que il est
de l'école primaire au lycée il a été vu
comme par hasard en 2016 après les
attentats et enfin c'est Samuel Paty a
enseigné ce cours et en est mort en fait
donc on n'est pas sur quelque chose de
complètement anodin alors quand on le
regarde donc vous héritez de ça de 2016
et il a été beaucoup pensé à l'époque
pour se dire comment on va faire pour
que ça ne se reproduise plus
donc très centré sur la lutte contre les
violences en fait et les radicalisme
voilà mais quand on regarde ça dans ces
moments ici c'est 80% de morale et 20%
de civique pour aller vite et le civique
n'est pas du politique alors j'ai pas
qu'il faut faire de la politique en
classe mais la politique ça renseigne
aussi la citoyenneté ça s'enseigne donc
le civique c'est une présentation peut
des institutions la justice la
séparation des fois c'est absolument
utile mais ça donne pas forcément le
goût de l'engagement le goût de
s'inscrire dans un parti politique etc
alors il y a des expériences qui
marchent bien il y a des enseignants qui
aiment ça il y a des hussards encore de
la République c'est pas les la haute
fonction publique ça c'est les street
level bureaucrates comment on dit et
ceux qui sont animés par ça font des
sorties montrent des documentaires et et
ça marche et ce qu'on voit c'est que
ceux qui n'étaient pas les héritiers de
ces citoyenneté acquises et bien sorte
avec alors ce que l'autrice qui a fait
cette thèse qui s'appelle madame amilate
appelle un capital culturel politique
une conscience une envie un goût de
faire quelque chose à la condition que
il est peut-être un peu plus de place
pour alors le civique ça rassure
davantage si on dit c'est civique si on
dit politique ça a fait ça va ça va
chahuter mais je pense que il est pas
vin cette enseignement d'abord il a
produit déjà des effets et on peut le
prendre avec encore plus de sérieux je
sais que les professeurs
d'histoire-géographie l'utilisent
souvent pour compléter leurs programmes
j'espère qu'il m'écoutent pas j'espère
qu'il y en a pas trop mais voilà je
pense qu'il faut le lui donner de
l'important c'est peut-être rééquilibrer
pour que on pense vraiment que c'était
un droit et que ce droit on veut l'avoir
on veut l'obtenir et on veut l'exercer
merci beaucoup juste pour ajouter une
chose à ce que vous dites qui me semble
tout à fait important sur le travail
effectivement de l'enseignement il y a
des choses aussi très importantes qui
sont faites par les collectivités
locales sur le civisme et qui marche
très bien et je sais que les nombreux
élus qui sont présents ici et les mers
qui qui sont à nos côtés l'utilise et
ses conseils municipaux de jeunes
qui ne sont pas forcément obligatoires
qui sont parfois
et ben voilà mais c'est quelque chose
qui est utilisé je sais que par les élus
en tout cas du MoDem elles sont très
très promues dans nos dans nos
collectivités j'y crois tu es élu sur
ces questions on l'a on l'a fait ça
marche très bien ça permet aux jeunes de
toute condition de toutes origines de
s'impliquer dans la ville locale et je
tenais juste à faire cet aparté pour
vous laisser la parole chacun une minute
de conclusion sur ce sujet on n'a pas
d'autres questions de la salle pour le
moment donc
si il y en a une ah bon je vous laisse
la parole elle est courte
c'était par SMS les questions
ah d'accord
[Musique]
juste avant elle
[Applaudissements]
donc merci pour votre intervention et
évidemment vous avez le droit à la
parole il n'y a pas de problème ici
juste pour terminer donc une minute
chacun de conclusion sur ce sujet
très vite je vous laisse la parole
volontiers le 2 observations vous aurez
constaté que à la tribune nous sommes 5
on est quatre en basket depuis qu'on
fait partie de la majorité
présidentielle avec les marcheurs nous
voilà désormais équipés
[Rires]
deuxième observation j'étais très
heureux de vous retrouver ce week-end
pour moi qui ai fait un petit accident
cardiaque au mois de février dernier
pour le plaisir de vous avoir retrouvé
je suis heureux que de battre mon cœur
de ce soit pas arrêté voilà
compliqué de prendre la suite
mais vous savez quoi vous savez le
sourire qu'on vient de ressentir la joie
de se retrouver et de se dire que oui
quand nous on est dans notre famille
politique on n'a pas tabou et que oui on
va aller chercher des combats et des
totems et ben moi c'est ce qui me donne
plaisir année après année en fait nos 10
ans à Guidel aujourd'hui et bien d'être
fier de notre partie d'être fier des
combats qu'on mène d'être fier de nos
parlementaires des élus locaux qui même
sur des terres extrêmement difficiles et
bien il lâche pas l'affaire on n'est pas
on n'est pas des passagers clandestins
de la démocratie on va chez nous on
navigue pas
on papillonne pas on s'encre on assume
nos territoires on assume nos histoires
et je pense que si un parti en tout cas
une famille une histoire qui peut créer
de la confiance recréer de la confiance
parce que moi ce que je vois c'est une
génération qui a besoin d'actes ils ont
beaucoup entendu de mots ils ont
beaucoup entendu de discours ils ont
oui il y a tout ça mais là ils veulent
des preuves et les profs c'est à nous de
les donner et l'épreuve elles sont pas
qu'au moment des échéances électorales
elles sont évidemment dans la
composition de nos listes elles sont
évidemment dans le choix de nos
candidats mais elle est elles sont aussi
dans la responsabilité sur dans nos
fédérations dans nos territoires alors
soyons de ceux qui font ne soyez ne
soyons pas que ceux qui imaginent et qui
projette des thèses soyons les
bâtisseurs soyons les tisserans et pour
être les tisserands et bien moi j'ai
comme ça en j'ai un projet j'ai une idée
faisons que c'est ce conseil national de
la refondation et bien finalement on en
applique la philosophie sur nos
territoires faisons que on soit des
ambassadeurs de ce service national
universel qui est d'abord un projet de
notre famille parce que c'est un creuset
républicain c'est ce moment où on va
aller créer du capital politique dans
des chez des jeunes chez des jeunes qui
peut-être n'en n'auraient pas et c'est
et c'est triste de se dire que
finalement tout ça ne l'aurait pas
ouvert simplement parce qu'il ne le
savent pas parce qu'ils nous en ont pas
conscience et nous on peut être de ceux
qui ouvrent les portes et les fenêtres
alors nous on va arrêter de juger on va
simplement éviter les cycles on va
ouvrir et on va aller finalement trouver
ces associations les accompagner invités
ce qui nous challenge et accepter
parfois de changer d'avis si on se fait
finalement convaincre et ça sera notre
force et je crois que c'est ce qui fait
en tout cas notre particularité
aujourd'hui dans le monde politique et
dans le fond si on donne à chacun sa
place et sa chance alors on sera de ce
finalement on sera
héritier de l'histoire qu'elle a notre
et on réussira à recréer du lien
elle est sympa elle me souhaite bon
courage
et derrière
non mais alors moi je suis un peu j'ai
envie de répondre à la question c'est
peut-être mon côté bon élève je ne sais
pas comment peut-on faire encore société
je crois que c'est la confiance
la confiance qui est un rebâtir et comme
pour l'amour je crois que finalement il
y a des preuves de confiance et merci
merci pour le soutien
et donc finalement c'est quoi ces
épreuves de confiance et bien c'est que
alors sans reprendre cette expression
galvaudée on dit ce qu'on fait on fait
ce qu'on dit mais quelque part quand
même ça c'est un lien avec ça c'est à
dire que c'est incarné
ce qu'on fait
dire ce qu'on pense je suis désolé de le
dire comme ça mais c'est c'est vraiment
à mon sens voilà le démarrage quand vous
rencontrez quelqu'un vous le regardez
dans les yeux vous l'écoutez et même si
vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec lui et
bien il y a cette relation qui se crée
cette confiance qui qui doit se faire
donc comment est-ce qu'on recréer la
confiance de nos concitoyens dans nos
institutions et dans les élus et ben
c'est pas une mince affaire en tout cas
on a bossé sur le sujet on a des
solutions et j'ai envie de vous dire et
ben il y a plus qu'à
non allez merci Julien en tout cas mais
si mais si un mot quand même ah bah oui
et ben j'ai envie de vous dire que
inventer la démocratie d'aujourd'hui je
trouve que c'est le l'un des plus beaux
projets qui puisse exister pour un parti
politique comme le vôtre donc en quelque
sorte vous avez de merveilleuses années
devant vous à militer à
convaincre et à inventer donc bonne
route merci
merci alors François
un plaisir viens ici
[Musique]
non je ne veux je ne veux rien ajouter
sauf une chose je veux rien ajouter
parce que j'ai beaucoup apprécié le
débat je veux dire que deux surcroît
j'ai apprécié tous les débats depuis ce
matin que j'ai suivi là-bas depuis le
depuis le fond de la salle que j'ai
trouvé brillant intelligent etc mais je
veux simplement vous dire que
s'il y a un universitaire français qui
nous a suivi depuis 30 ans quasiment 25
ans
oui une partie non non
qui nous a suivi depuis l'origine c'est
Julien fratel
qui est venu souvent anonymement dans
tous nos congrès
qui a fait des panels comme on dit de
nos militants qui les a interviewés qui
a étudié et qui a publié sur nous et
c'est assez
marquant pour qu'on puisse par nos
applaudissements lui dire qu'on a
apprécié en tout cas moi j'ai beaucoup
apprécié
voilà juste pour vous remercier pour
votre participation pour votre présente
pour votre écoute attentive remercier
nos invités François pour pour ces mots
et et vous dire que j'étais ravi aussi
de vous retrouver et de pouvoir animer
[Applaudissements]